-Hey, everyone!
Thank you very, very much.
And welcome to
"The Tonight Show."
Let's get to the news and jokes.
Well, guys, this morning,
the Commission on
Presidential Debates,
which I'm assuming is
just a bunch of guys with
bird masks and butt paddles,
made a big announcement
about the
next presidential debate.
Listen to this.
-The commission just announcing
that the next debate
will be entirely virtual as the
president still battles COVID.
The candidates will participate
from separate remote locations.
-Yeah, a virtual debate...
with two guys in their 70s
and a moderator in his 60s.
I'm sure that'll
run real smooth.
And to make it
even more annoying,
they're going to have
Trump and Biden
chomp on baby carrots
while they talk.
[ Chomping ]
A virtual debate with Trump?
Come on.
How great would that be?
It's like, "Melania,
what's the Wi-Fi password?"
[ Slovenian accent ]
1, 2, 3, 4 --
same as nuke codes."
[ Normal voice ] Yeah, a virtual
debate seems like a safe idea.
During a phone call this morning
on "Fox Business,"
Trump was asked about it,
and here's what he had to say.
-The CPD, the Commission
on Presidential Debates,
announcing this morning
that the second presidential
debate will be virtual.
Are you saying
you're not going to participate?
-Yep, Trump says
he won't waste time.
Then he went back to chatting on
Fox Business for 55 minutes.
55 minutes.
Halfway through,
Maria Bartiromo texted
the hosts of
"Fox & Friends" like,
"How do you make him stop?"
Seriously, the call
was so exhausting,
Maria went online and booked
four days at Walter Reed.
After Trump stated that
he would not "waste his time,"
Joe Biden announced that he was
backing out of
the debate, as well.
It's like a group text.
Once one person bails on brunch,
the floodgates open,
and everybody jumps ship.
They're like,
"Uh, I got something, too.
Yeah, yeah. Sorry.
Well, I forgot about that."
It's too bad for the people
who were going to speak
at the town hall,
'cause they were
really looking forward
to having their questions
ignored on national television.
Anyway, back to
Trump's phone call.
Maria asked the president
how he's doing,
and it was clear that Trump
is having a tough time
staying in quarantine.
Listen to this.
-A rally?
He's actually considering that?
Trump's aides were like,
"You got it, boss,"
then put him in a room with
5,000 cardboard cutouts.
Later in the interview,
Trump had a sound bite
that I found very interesting.
Check this out.
-[ As Trump ] Whaaat?
Wha...
I've never felt better.
My body is a finely tuned
Swiss clock.
Everything is in
perfect working order.
[ Normal voice ]
"So happy you're better."
[ As Trump ] Whaaat?
[ Normal voice ] Trump suddenly
turned into every grandpa
when you ask
how they're feeling.
"What?"
Also, minor detail --
there's no such thing
as being immune to COVID.
After he said that,
Dr. Fauci poured himself
a big antibody cocktail
minus the antibody.
Towards the
end of the interview,
Maria had a question about
Trump's current COVID status,
and he gave her a
pretty interesting answer.
Listen to this.
-You're feeling good.
Have you been tested recently?
Can you tell us anything else
about your condition?
-Essentially?
This is kind of
a binary situation.
You either have COVID
or you don't.
Doctors don't say, "Good news.
You don't have COVID anymore...
more or less.
Per se."
That's not very comforting.
You don't see a celebrity coming
out of rehab like, "All good.
I'm essentially clean."
Well, guys, last night
was, of course,
the big vice-presidential
debate between
Mike Pence and Kamala Harris,
and everyone's
still talking about it
because a fly
actually landed on Pence's head.
Watch this.
-Yes.
-It's a great insult
to the men and women
who serve in law enforcement.
-Part of a pattern of
Donald Trump's.
He was...
-At that point,
every American was like,
"Is that on him or on my TV?"
You know vice-presidential
debates are boring
when a fly shows up and the
entire Internet loses its mind.
Meanwhile, a bunch of other
flies off-camera were like,
"Oh, my God.
I can't believe
you actually did it!
You're a legend, dude!
Epic!
I can't believe you did it!"
Kamala Harris was probably
sitting there thinking,
"I've been
strong and commanding,
and all anyone is
going to be talking about
is that stupid fly."
Yeah, that was
a tough moment for Pence,
although it's still not
as bad as
the last
vice-presidential debate,
when a barn owl attacked
Tim Kaine.
Yep, Pence had a rough night.
As if the fly wasn't bad enough,
people also noticed
there was something
going on with his eyeball.
Look at his eye.
Yeah, he's the head of
the Coronavirus Task Force.
Not really a great look when
you're covered in bugs
and bleeding out of your eye.
Yep, last night's debate
was an epic battle
between side-eye and red-eye.
It's a tough break for Pence.
It's hard to shake
the reputation of being robotic
when you show up looking like
the Terminator.
Also, can you believe
Kamala Harris
had to stare at that
for 90 minutes?
As if she wasn't under
enough pressure,
she had to debate the Bond
villain with the leaky eye.
[ As Le Chiffre ]
Be very careful, Mr. Bond.
[ Normal voice ]
People are worried about Pence
because pinkeye is a possible
symptom of coronavirus.
Even scarier, today,
Pence's temperature
shot all the way up to 84.6.
Well, a lot of people also
noticed that Pence
kept interrupting Harris,
but she wasn't having it.
Watch this.
-This is important, and I want
to add --
-Susan, I have to weigh in here.
-Mr. Vice President,
I'm speaking.
-I have to weigh in.
-I'm speaking.
...raise taxes on anybody who
makes less than $400,000 a year.
-He said he's going to repeal
the Trump tax cuts.
-Mr. Vice President,
I'm speaking.
-Well --
-I'm speaking.
If you don't mind letting
me finish,
we can then
have a conversation, okay?
-Please.
-Okay.
In 1864 --
-Well, I'd like you
to answer the question.
-Mr. Vice President,
I'm speaking.
I'm speaking. Okay?
[ Laughter, applause ]
-Compared to
the presidential debate,
that wasn't too bad,
although that's like comparing
a five-star restaurant to
a Waffle House at 3:00 a.m.
That's right -- there were
a lot of memorable moments
during the debate, and there are
plenty of jokes to be made,
but if it's alright,
I want to take a moment
to say something serious
about democracy.
That okay?
-You asking me?
I mean, it's your show, man.
You can do whatever you want.
-America is at an
inflection point right now.
And we, as a nation, have to
come together to make a choice.
-[ Laughs ] Um, Jimmy,
you got something on your, uh...
-This country needs to
ask itself some hard questions,
like, "What is America?
Who is freedom?
And when is liberty?"
-That didn't even make --
You know what?
I don't care, man.
Just keep doing your thing.
-So get out there
and be the change
you want to see in the world.
-Jimmy...
-Uh, yeah? What's up, Tariq?
Something you want to tell me?
-I just wanted to say
that was beautiful.
-You trim your beard
or something?
You look different.
-No, man.
There's a [bleep]
squirrel on my head.
-Well, listen to this.
I saw that
the governor of California
has a new recommendation
for residents
to safely eat at restaurants
during the pandemic.
-The governor's office
tweeted out, saying,
when you're eating out
at a restaurant,
to keep your mask on
in between bites of food.
The tweet even shows an image
of someone wearing a mask,
then not wearing a mask,
taking a bite,
and then putting
the mask back on again.
-So you have to
pull your mask down.
You take a bite.
Then you put your mask back on,
you chew, swallow, then repeat.
Or you could just
fill your mask with food
and eat like a horse.
Even Donald Trump was like...
"Whaaat?"
This is interesting.
I saw that,
starting in November,
Singapore will
offer cruises to nowhere.
So they're basically
just going to go out,
float, and come back.
So if you're tired of
being cooped up at home,
try it in a smaller room
that rocks back and forth.
Normally, if someone invites you
on a cruise to nowhere,
you're like "Okay, cool.
I'm about to be murdered."
Seriously, I'm pretty sure
"Cruise to Nowhere"
is the name of
every "Dateline" episode.
"They had the perfect marriage.
Then they booked two tickets on
a cruise...to nowhere."
Speaking of traveling,
I saw that hotels.com
is offering a stay
in a pretty
interesting destination.
-Hotels.com
is offering a unique escape.
After casting your early ballot,
you can enter a contest
to live under a rock
during election week.
It's a man-made cave
built 50 feet below ground.
-The website's great.
It's like, "Oh, we got
a king-sized bed.
You got a Jacuzzi, mole people."
And, finally,
a café in Prague is getting
a lot of attention
for its new dessert.
Check it out.
-There's a café in Prague which
is looking to, well,
lighten the mood amid
a slump in business
because of the pandemic.
Owners debuted
a dessert cake shaped
like the novel coronavirus
in an effort to draw customers.
-Yeah, they're really into
the whole theme.
When you order it,
the server puts it in his mouth
and spits it back
into yours like a baby bird.